m
durant les vacances scolaires le coin
des enfants de l'espace règle et propose
aux petits de participer aux siestes
sonores une lecture d'environ 20 minutes
dans une atmosphère calme décontracté
été tendue alors une ciste sonore le
principe c'est devant venir se poser
profiter du coin des enfants de
s'allonger parmi les poussins sur le
tapis de lecture et d'écouté en fait on
a perdu l'habitude d'écouter les enfants
n'ont pas tous la chance d'avoir des
lectures le soir avant de se coucher
ils sont dans une société où il bouge
beaucoup l'âme à la bibliothèque même
coin des enfants ils viennent ils
zappent il passe du je au dessin à la
lecture
voilà donc la sieste sonas et se poser
pendant un quart d'heure vingt minutes
et se laisser porter par la voix du
conteur celui ci nous agite la grande
étant donc au de saint benoît puis il
explora l'arrière dumas sans résultat ne
se découragea pas il ce bris tôt je
n'avais pas pu disparaître et les
produits très montagneux au fret une
cachette idéale pour les islais en fuite
le coin des enfants a fait le choix de
conter une histoire d'isabelle waro
femme de lettres réunionnaise
l'occasion pour les enfants de découvrir
et de comprendre l'histoire de leur île
nous sortons du mois du patrimoine avec
les journées du patrimoine
et nous avions découvert ce conte un
décompte phare autour du piton
d'anchaing de mirabel waro et les
enfants allaient beaucoup aimé
aujourd'hui c'était des enfants
différents et petits nouveaux des
enfants qui n'étaient pas venus depuis
un moment donc
j'ai eu vraiment envie de communiquer de
lire ce compte qui vous avait beaucoup
plu et qui a vraiment marqué les esprits
et je sais qu'il ya beaucoup d'enfants
maintenant de du bas-de-la-rivière
d'ailleurs un qui viennent qui
connaissent maintenant l'histoire du
piton d'anchaing et du qui savent ce
qu'est un python ce qui n'était pas le
cas avant